hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to hell was here now this is
another FPS horror creator game thing
thing thing whatever I'm saying um
usually I don't really like these games
but these have managed to startle me as
of late and you guys seem to like it
when I get startled now they may not be
the pinnacle of horror have oh thank you
so much I like this one already because
it doesn't make the use button enter
which means that I don't have
did you guys see Zalman maybe they've
been lying so physics are enabled which
is a marvel of modern game design that
one excuse me I'm beginning to wonder
did I actually see something there was
it just like a shadow or I think there
aren't any shadows in this game so it
must have been something okay well this
is going to be delightful isn't it
ooh an office anyway I actually skipped
a bit of the intro sequence it was a bit
long but um oh hello can i press f to
take the key card that is not a key card
but I'm not gonna question you on that
one
so yeah what does he go to this door
over here or is this just the exit door
nope okay never mind we've got to be
another door upstairs or summer
so the thumpy thump starts and there's
nothing over here
oh yeah anything gonna pop out of me who
do I me who's in front of me oh it's a
wall
John the bad you watch me come with me
on the bed okay moving on
oh is that the room good
all right that's how it's gonna be huh
don't do that to me
screw you oh why that close by me going
on here there another key hello he he
oh there it is give it to me try to
press em oh there we go expand F they
just worked I gotta say not bad so far
got any more to throw me was it oh just
a lantern Wow rather Spartan wine
collection you have here I see that
you're a look who's that
alright some heard some
hey I'm just waiting for it to throw
something at me because I know these
types of games just they throw jump
scares at you and that's it
Oh an empty room huh okay way to see
whatever lies oh oh nothing nothing
oh wait was there like a key in here oh
no I already have a key I don't think
there's any more doors to be unlocked
after that one I'm gonna happen happen
okay never mind
gonna move on over here unlock this door
and open the door get on the floor all
right Dylan Iser how about you shut up
okay
oh look a lovely radio an electric chair
I don't see how the two are connected
but okay all right what's the point
what's the point of this I love how
there's grates on the floor to drain the
blood but it's not doing a good job
what's that what's the point of this
this time I'm told to do what's going on
here what's going on here I don't see
like a key on the floor nothing I'm
really looking guys I'm trying to I'm
pressing my use button um oh I can dance
a little jig here in celebration of us
all murdering each other which is always
nice always a nice thing but other than
that I really don't see anything guys
the hell what's going on
well as I slew the radio for help help
help the crazed blood snapper is after
me wow this doesn't make sense
oh I kid it wait a minute there this
isn't blood it's wine some drunk bastard
was walking through these halls I
decided to lottie dottie yes you're that
la dee da dee da walk through a place
get in here and he shocked himself that
Bethany bloated his wine everywhere oh
come on don't do like this you were
doing good you had me startled there on
the edge of my seat
leave a kind of oh wow what the hell
okay all right I was wandering for a
while just kind of taking in the
atmosphere and the heartbeats because I
didn't know what to do
and I walked in here and the music
stopped or the heartbeat whatever and
it's pilot
okay okay I got the file
not only took forever then again I
didn't really think to move around I
thought that was I really thought there
was something to that room other than
what there was though Bob and I
apologize for my own stupidity because
I'm horrifically dumb in every way but
oh so charming right guys
mon Dieu egg pie well thank you there we
all God what I see a gun what is this
place seems to be the asylum I remember
I took the file and then that shadow I
have to take a look around with this gun
would feel blow hi didn't see it whoa
what the hell oh okay sorry I didn't see
you there buddy
take that you know look like you need it
all right I'm ready I'm ready
come on game you still got me it's to
lose to me make me scared make me pee my
pants I'm not wearing any pants but that
don't matter
nothing game you got this you got me in
the Palmer this light does nothing that
don't matter somehow my little keychain
flashlight cast okay so that's how it's
gonna be again we'll bring it on I'm
ready for you this time
scare me good contrary to popular belief
I actually do like to be scared to an
extent thoroughly enjoy or games
especially good ones but I do enjoy the
good cheap adrenaline rush of a jump
scare it's not bad I mean it doesn't
make a game great but it still makes it
kind of I heard that again oh god what
the hell who does Maggie that
you bet yeah uh hell yeah all right I
killed the shadow good for me huh
whoa all right yeah that's what I'm
talking about I mean
sub-tabs hear that again sometimes it
actually is just fun to get startled
like oh you are yeah I can't see you I
wish mother for you big money there we
go yeah yeah but didn't that ah one shot
one kill baby oh yeah I'm out of ammo
well that's not good I'm out of am row I
don't know where to find anymore I hope
there's no more monsters Hey oh my mom
a giant syringe what is this supposed to
go up someone's ass I hope not cuz I
would be awful
oh okay [ __ ] god dammit stop it Jesus
I don't I can't kill you I don't have
any bullets so I'm just gonna ignore you
for now oh god damn it
dead end don't kill me don't kill me bro
are you doing bro oh wow Jesus hey don't
be like that mr. long arms if you did
hit me with your arms no I don't know
I like that shut off everybody you got
the dirtiest mind in the world stop
thinking so weirdly okay so this place
is bigger than I thought
ass go speak and so I don't know I need
to find a lot of keys oh god dammit stop
doing that man okay so there are other
pathways but I'm gonna assume that
there's a shadowy apparition at a return
he's gonna get me he's gonna smack me
with his tentacle ah I don't want it
okay ah here we are
nothing in here ah fudge damn it I'm
dead
oh all right I gotta wrap Adam uh-oh the
dead end
there's gotta be some value in here oh
I'm so dead I'm so dad oh my god us I've
done I didn't save hey hey
get out of way no no UFO there's nothing
in here now you son of a now don't do
that to me okay apparently it was
supposed to be one shot one kill and I
did not do that correctly so I'm gonna
go back cuz I probably got to start from
the beginning but now that I know what
to do it's gonna take me like no time at
all uh you gonna stay the night are you
gonna stay gonna stay the night are you
gonna pay the night my god I stay the
night
uh are you gonna stay the night okay all
right I'm back in case you didn't notice
I was singing oh you gotta stay the
night
oh you got God that has got to be the
most repetitious than boring song I've
ever heard and it's just a polite way of
saying it's like are you gonna [ __ ] me
why are you gonna you wanna sleep with
me you are bang my boo goo that's all it
is it's all that song is yeah say to
them shatter everyone's illusion to what
that song is all about but there ain't
no secrets about that one people have
been singing about dad for years but
anyway I don't know what I'm doing here
um I kind of went a little loopy on the
bottle cut damn it stop doing that with
your stiff neck yeah here I don't think
there's anything that I need in there so
I probably how many bullets do I have I
have six bullets how is that even fair
okay so anyway I have six bullets to
take care of these [ __ ] and find
whatever the hell it is I need to find
which frankly I don't even know okay
this is where there's one down this oh
where is this no this is completely
different okay so anyway this is gonna
be a nightmare and a half trying to find
all these bastards or find all the
stupid-ass things that I need I don't
even know where to look or what to look
for Oh Jimmy are you done we're done
here
what was that you're just gonna growl at
me and then that's the end of it oh god
damn it mother humper Jesus balls huh
where are you come on come on there was
lights lights in here okay you're right
where are you and you're not making
through those gaps in those doors oh you
went away
oh you're stuck okay stay right there
ah gotcha AHA [ __ ] who's this shadow
now you're just a shadow your former
self uh there's a little blood there
okay
okay God dingus was there nothing down
here what a crock of ass uh okay anyway
let me just double-check everything just
to be sure to be sure all right whatever
fine you know what I don't need I don't
need to progress I don't need to get it
to the end of this game I don't need to
he's great
this gun is just gonna be endless and
even if there is a key in here it's
gonna be extremely hard for me to find
it just because hey everything is
friggin monotonous and there's a lot of
it so what am I supposed to do about
that besides cry all I do is cry
look GRU you bass hole okay there's
blood over here does that mean that
there's something of import does that
mean that I need to find something over
here cuz if I do then I would love to be
able to find it anything you know hope
could you possibly any aging here oh god
there's nothing is there it's like I
need to find like three keys but I can't
even find one is screw all this there's
nothing here and even if I would is so
tiny then I would I be able to find it
how would I ever be able to my this is
just dead ends after dead ends after
dead ends and stupid shadow people
popping up hello I don't want to die I
want to live preferably for a good long
time till I'm like 40 or something it'll
be good enough for me okay
what's this tricycle here and then
nothing else there is no K here and what
is this some what is this why is that
even there why do I even bother asking
question thank you yeah I know
well I can't find anything oh holy hell
all right fine I'm wait what no no no I
refused there's got to be something in
here there was a voice it was like
herwise Diane I'm like whoa no no I
drowned rather not no there's nothing in
here dingus damn it it wasn't even a oh
hi there wasn't even a shadow guy in
there what's the point of all this
then kill my wife I didn't kill her you
know you're here
where are you know you were here don't
lie to me don't lie to me Jack Hoel you
were here were cured you know you were I
didn't get to look through these areas
very closely because of the shadow guy
that was trying to eat my balls
no nothing whole lot of nothing where
are you I know you're gonna jump out at
me mr. shadow man this is nothing here
nothing maybe it's randomly generated
that actually would not surprise me cuz
I mean I know that there was a shadow
guy there before and then all sudden he
was you know how do you explain that
hell god damn it
not even that scary it's just like no
it's jad again thank you very much
have a good day in hell this game was
just getting too long and kind of got on
my nerves I had to split it up into two
part but don't worry it'll be out very
very soon just click on this box here
when it's available and you'll be taken
right to the epic conclusion or
something like that anyway you'll see
what I mean thank you all so much have a
good day
theater I don't see anything if I missed
something guys please bring me in the
comment